welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and watch out y'all i'm about to do it
i'm about to say a huge spoiler for the
mid-credits scene for marvel's eternals
in like five seconds so like make like
icarus and fly away from this video if
you have not seen chloe zhao's newest
banger because after aresham showed up
in the sky one harry styles dropped by
to say watermelon sugar high as arrows
of titan most prominently known as star
fox in the marvel comet not to be
confused with star fox the nintendo
games that nintendo refuses to make
anymore why i love star fox 64. do a
barrel roll but hey just who is pip the
trolls bestie eros anyway well you guys
already know that i got you guys the
lowdown on everything arrows already so
buckle up and get ready to learn my nerd
babies arose is of course the brother of
thanos and the son of his mother sui-san
and his father alar's aka mentor leader
of the eternals of titan a leader who
was name-dropped by red skull when he
got a visit from aeros brother thanos
and his niece on vormir in avengers
infinity war
[Music]
and arrows is most famously known in the
comics for three things one being an
avenger as one of the strongest eternals
in existence two recently being
accidentally responsible for the
resurrection of thanos after thanos died
which is a huge whoopsie and uh three
eternal horniness be like seriously like
if thanos is the mad titan eros is the
chad titan because mans be banging them
twice a night and then hanging them out
to dry all the clocks in eros's house
just say sexy time the reason why i said
eros is one of the most strongest
eternals alive in the universe has
entirely to do with the circumstances of
his birth because eros and his brother
thanos are actually one of the few
eternals to ever be born from a union of
two eternals boning together because as
i've noticed in a previous video the
celestials kind of engineered it for
eternals to be completely unable to
reproduce amongst themselves it's
probably their way of ensuring that the
universe isn't like super overpopulated
by all these god people luckily for
alars and his wife sui-san they were
both giving two wedding ring size
versions of the cosmic energy
manipulating quantum bands by mentor's
father cronos which would allow sui-san
to bring eros's eternally horny ass self
to the world you're welcome world well
you know after you know suicide tried to
stab the evil purple ruffle chip that
came out of her hoo-ha the first time
her maternal instincts just knew that
she had just made a massive cosmic
mistake fortunately for suicide she
would have the chance to have a baby
that she wouldn't want to stab in the
face when arrows popped out not too long
after thanos and because eros was born
as a result of two eternals and the
cosmic power of the quantum bands which
are if you guys don't know what gives
the hero quasar their powers aeros's
standard eternal's powers are
significantly more enhanced than your
average eternals like he can you know
fly use super strength speed shoot
energy blasts cosmic telekinesis heal
himself just like all the other eternals
can but like you know four times is
better essentially because he has all
this you know cosmic juice in him arrows
pretty much has the durability of his
brother thanos and was able to take the
full force of a cosmic god blast to the
face by thanos himself once and live and
also like thanos arrows had an amazingly
sharp mind and was able to effortlessly
do things and access abilities that
other eternals would literally have to
spend countless years training to master
because of this fact arrows would become
an invaluable ally to the avengers when
you first met them during their first
ever takedown of the mad titan in the
original captain marvel comics you want
to hear something funny eros was not
even originally this dude's name mentor
and suicide originally gave him the name
eron however when everyone reached the
age of five five years old mentor and
sui-san quickly realized that aaron was
already obsessed with women so they
decided to name him arrows instead which
as some of you greek mythology nerds out
there may know is actually the greek
word for love as well as the name of the
greek god of passion and fertility and
boy oh boy was arrows passionate about
fertilizing the universe and this video
is brought to you by privacy privacy
lets you buy things online using virtual
cards protecting your identity and bank
information on the internet and as a
treat for mine viewers new customers get
five dollars to spend on their first
purchase when they go to privacy.com new
rockstars to sign up now privacy makes
it super easy to manage your financial
lives online while keeping your
information secure by generating virtual
numbers privacy masks your bank
information so you never have to worry
about giving it out to those baddies
lurking behind internet corners behind
those virtual bushes you can never trust
them do your online holiday shopping
this year with privacy cards which let
you set spend limits on each card and
pause and close cards anytime you want
and if a fraudulent transaction ever
occurs privacy will automatically
decline the transaction and notify you
immediately i like privacy for recurring
payments like streaming services i set
up a privacy account linked up my bank
account and created a card specifically
for my netflix subscription payment and
privacy will ding you if someone tries
to charge the car twice or if the charge
exceeds the amount that you set for it
so head to privacy.com new rockstars and
sign up for an account and new customers
will automatically get five dollars to
spend on your first purchase so go to
privacy.com
new rockstars and sign up to death and
in the comics arrows is very well known
for his role as earth's most mightily
inconsistent avenger i mean not because
you know he was inconsistent and
ineffective in battle eros just had a
tendency of leaving and rejoining the
avengers every now and then because of
his extreme and insatiable need for
stimulation you know stimulation in the
form of crazy new adventures and copious
amounts of sexual intercourse the wasp
did not give this man the name star fox
for nothing okay like the man gets it in
constantly one time he even took the
avenger tigra with him to party on the
pleasure planet of deneb seven where
they boned until boredom now erosion's
success with women over the years is
impressive but we can't really talk
about eros without talking about his
more problematic powers now i'm not
talking about his powers of empathy like
to bridge emotions between people manta
style like that's not very problematic
at all but i am talking about his
ability to make everyone around him feel
good by being able to cosmically
stimulate the pleasure receptors of the
human brain to get people to you know
either become highly euphoric sexually
aroused or just to get people just like
him as a person which has come in clutch
a couple of times in the comics when
he's needed to jedi mind tricks and bad
guys into you know bashfully looking the
other direction
still these powers are for sure not one
of marvel's best decisions and it looks
like marvel sort of knew this as well as
eros would eventually willingly ask the
psychic marvel hero moon dragon to
remove this power from his brain and in
himself completely after being
exonerated of charges of sexual
impropriety by she-hulk after learning
that thanos messed with his mind and
seducing powers in the past like i'm not
even joking this literally happened in a
she-hulk series from like 2005. go check
it out it's really weird yeah he went to
court yeah
thanos messing with arrows his mind
would not end there oh no cassano's
would absolutely prank his little white
boy brother again from the grave by
completely overriding eros's mind to
facilitate thanos resurrection after
eros assembled a team of extremely
powerful heroes called the dark
guardians to specifically prevent
thanos's resurrection from happening
because thanos died and he left a will
and he was like i'm coming back and i'm
gonna come back using somebody's body
and eros was like oh no but it turns out
it was aeros body the entire time whoops
you done messed up ee wrong and
unfortunately this big old youtube rink
would eventually lead to the end of
eros's erotic life completely but hey
look on the bright side arrows uh at
least
you didn't die a virgin but that is
arrows aka star fox one of the most
powerful heroes in the marvel universe
in a nutshell what do you guys think
about arrow styles do you guys think
arrows could even take on the likes of
like you know captain marvel or even the
incredible hulk because of his like
juiced up eternals powers let us know in
the comment section below my nerd babies
because i'm very curious to know what
you guys think but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird but most importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
twitter and on youtube and if you do on
youtube make sure to hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload dope
do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can get cool
shirts like this so you can make your
friends jealous and make girls and or
whatever gender that you're attracted to
think that you are the bee's knees thank
you guys so much for watching i love you
guys genuinely you guys are amazing make
my life amazing and wonderful and i'll
see you guys next time bye
[Music]
you